сьогодні в німецькому місті ахені
президентові України Володимиру
зеленському вручили премію Карла
Великого ця премія має велике значення
не тільки для Німеччини але і для всієї
Європи для всього Європейського Союзу
Володимир Зеленський
запізнився на годину разом з іншими
лідерами
Німеччини Польщі Європейського Союзу але
було варто звичайно очікувати
у цій будівлі яку ви зараз бачите за
моєю спиною тому що промови
усіх лідерів дійсно вражали Ну що я можу
розповісти про
незвичайні обставини дійсно сьогодні
вахені були дуже незвичайні обставини
тому що це місто ще не
безпеки які були запроваджені сьогодні
під час візиту Володимира Зеленського
на дахах на цій площі Де я зараз стою
зараз вже нема але сиділи снайпери їх
було було дуже добре видно люди
коментували що якось незручно якось не
дуже затишно себе почуваєш коли бачиш
звичайно і
снайперів і
стільки поліцейських поліцейських
сьогодні в ахені було приблизно тисяча
вони працювали не тільки тут але й в
усьому місті наприклад центр міста ахина
був абсолютно заблокований для всіх хто
хотів гуляти вулицями чи дивитися якісь
цікаві туристичні будівлі
[музика]
як собор сьогодні Це було взагалі
неможливо тому що його центр міста
заблокували і можна було було пройти
тільки з акредитацією наприклад
журналіста але навіть журналістам було
дуже важко працювати сьогодні тому що
працювати взагалі цілий день
не був Зеленський тому що звичайно
журналістів водили всіх разом не можна
було перетнути площу не можна було вийти
зали або якщо ти виходиш зали де
нагороджували Зеленського вже не можна
було повернутися до неї і
так було трошки важко я маю сказати але
ми тут з вами і я хочу розповісти вам ще
про те що відбувалося сьогодні на цій
церемонії
дуже цікаві промови в яких наприклад
урсулах
що
майбутнє України з Європою майбутнє
України в Європі і запевнила
Волинського та виїзд український народ
який сьогодні також разом з ним звичайно
отримував всю премію в тому що Україна
буде Європа буде підтримувати Україну
стільки скільки треба
канцлер Німеччини колах шольц сьогодні
сказав що це
перша частина
нової подорожі
України
разом з Німеччиною разом з Європою треба
сказати що це був перший візит
Зеленського до Німеччини з початку
повномасштабного вторгнення сам
Зеленський жартував під час своєї
промови імпровізував і
навіть після промови після церемонії
українці спілка українців в ахені казали
що вони бачать що бачать що Зеленський
втомлений але вони раді що він ще може
жартувати що він не втратив свого
почуття гумору що сказав Зеленський
Зеленський сказав що
звичайно Україна очікує
конкретних кроків
по вступу до НАТО і що Україна довела що
вона вже де-факто є членом НАТО але що
бракує зафіксувати це формально на
папері ця премія означає в першу чергу
Ти що
в Німеччині та в Європейському Союзі
дуже добре розуміють що Україна захищає
не тільки себе що Україна захищає не
тільки свою свободу а і цінності всього
Європейського Союзу і також свободу
Європейського Союзу від російської
агресії дуже цікаву речі сказав
Володимир Зеленський він сказав
вийдете на вулицю а подивитися навколо
для себе і ви відчуєте свободу яка тут
просто є А українці за цю свободу зараз
воюють але вони переможуть
і
ще дуже багато
дуже багато емоційних моментів було
сьогодні на церемонії дуже гарна музика
[оплески]
українські вірші
їм Європи люди під час церемонії дуже
багато обливали Після виступу
Зеленського аплодували майже дві хвилини
безперерви взагалі йому аплодували
більше ніж іншим лідерам можна сказати
що буквально після кожної завершеної
думки
лунали аплодисменти в залі після цього
німці українці Люди які були присутні
вони обмінювалися враженнями і казали що
це було
справді справді дуже
зворушливо справді дуже
звичайно емоційно і
люди дуже раділи тому що це відбулося і
що вони побачили На власні очі такий
історичний момент